كره القدم ما هي الرياضه الاكثر شعبيه ولا
طالما شهدت دورا كبيرا للمهاجرين في
المونديال الاول عام 1930 خمسه في المئه
فقط من اللاعبين وولدوا خارج الدول التي
مثلتها رقم قليل مقارنه بالمونديال الحالي
لاعب من كل سته لاعبين مثلوا دوله غير
التي ولد فيها
اختلاف في الارقام بين الماضي والحاضر لكن
التاثير ثابته في مونديال
1934 مثلا خمسه لاعبين مولودونا في امريكا
الجنوبيه ساعدوا ايطاليا بلد اجدادهم
للفوز باول القابها الموندياليه واحد هم
الوسمونتي ربح اللقب الاول الرقبه
لكن اليوم الهجره هجره الامس
لايطاليي الارجنتين لم تغير ولاى واحد من
افضل اللاعبين الارجنتيني الينا المسي
الذي ولد جده الاكبر في ريكان نات
ريكاناتي الايطاليه ركانتي الايطاليه قبل
ان ينتقل الى الارجنتين عام
1893 ما اسباب هذه الظاهره اذا الاسباب
وعده من بينها هجره اباء اللاعبين
واجدادهم بشكلها الطبيعي واسبابها
المختلفه المثال هنا يا كندا دوله مهاجرين
فكان منتخبنا مهاجرا بامتياز 22 لاعب من
اصل اربعه وعشرين اصولهم غير كنديه
واشهرهم الفون السعوديه
في غانا لابوين من ليبيا
سببا اخر وهو اللعب باسمي موطن الاباء
والاجداد وهذه النقطه تحديدا تضعفت خلال
العقدين الماضيين حقيقه تنعكس بوضوح في
حاله المغرب ثلاثه لاعبين فقط من مواليد
الخارج شاركوا مع المنتخب خلال اربع
بطولات لكاس العالم بين عام
1970 و
19980 لكن المغرب اليوم بها 14 لاعبا
مولودنا في الخارج مثل اشرف حكيمي ولد
ونشا في مدريد واخرجت ضربته بالترجيحيه
اسبانيا تحديدا